- All right, it's always
nice to end the show
with one last bit of happiness
I found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
I'm super passionate about
getting my kids to read
and they like it, and here
they are this morning.
Yep.
(crowd awing)
That's how, like you walk in their room
and they were reading to each other.
And I was like, look, I
didn't completely screw up.
(crowd laughing)
But not all kids
have someone outside school
pushing them to pick up books.
That's why a former New York teacher
is filling hundreds of barbershops,
coast to coast, with reading materials
that pique kids' minds
and creative thinking,
which is super important.
It's a great initiative to highlight
as we prepare for giving Tuesday.
From Barbershop Books, let's everybody
say hello to Alvin
watching on NBC New York.
(crowd cheering)
Hi Alvin.
Oh we have several of
those books in my house.
My kids love Captain Underpants.
So, so tell everybody what this is
and the origin story of it.
- Barbershop Books' mission
is to inspire Black boys
and other vulnerable
children to read for fun,
and also to identify as readers.
We create child-friendly reading spaces
in Black barbershops
and other barbershops across the country.
And we provide early
literacy training to barbers.
About 10 years ago, I
was getting a haircut
across the street from the school
where I taught first grade.
And one of my students
came into the barbershop
and he got a little antsy,
he looked a little bored.
And I just kept thinking,
oh I wish I had a
children's book to give him.
And so, you know, understanding
the cultural significance
of the barbershop
inspired me to create Barbershop Books.
- I love it man.
So this is more than about reading,
it's about community, right?
- Yeah.
For many Black boys,
they have limited access
to Black male reading role models.
Less than 2% of teachers are Black males
and a majority of Black boys
are raised by a single mother.
And so there's a lack
of reading role models
at school and at home, but they go
to the barbershop once or twice a month.
And so it creates this unique opportunity
to promote reading.
- Yeah,
it's an interesting space to read.
And what a smart thing too, 'cause yeah
we're always taking our
kids to get their haircuts.
That's awesome for them
to be able to do that,
instead of just like the coloring section.
You know? It's very cool.
Thank you Alvin.
This is such a cool initiative.
I'm liking your post right now,
all right?
(bell dings)
(crowd cheering)
All right everybody,
that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson
Show," want to celebrate
those creating another generation
of readers just like you.
So they're giving Barbershop
Books a thousand dollars,
just to help out with material.
(crowd cheering)
- Thanks, I appreciate it.
- Thank you Alvin.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Kevin Bacon, Ego Nwodim, Lawrence Zarian,
and Kevin Quinn.
Y'all have a great day.
(crowd cheering)
And if it's not, try and change it.